Okay. Hi everyone. Thank you for joining
us on
Friday, June 26th. Uh typically Frasier
Patterson would be kind of leading the
discussion on this day. Uh he's
unfortunately not feeling well. Um I've
of course been assisting for the uh
textbook group uh not just for this
entire session but uh in previous years
as well uh teaching the previous 2022
textbook and now we've been having a
good time with looking at the new
fundamentals of active inference
textbook that came out a couple months
ago. Um so we're still on chapter 5 just
sort of wrapping it up. Today is the
last day. Um, and then I want to give a
quick announcement that next week, as
opposed to jumping to part six of the
textbook, we'll be kind of re-reviewing
the entirety of part one of the textbook
is a sort of interim session. Um,
that'll allow us to sort of go back over
chapters 1 through 5, maybe in a more
cursory uh overview sort of fashion. Um
it is important as we go forward given
that part two of the textbook which will
start with chapter 6 uh will start to
get into active inference itself. We're
still not quite there. Um there's been
quite a bit to cover and so many of the
core things that we've seen include
hidden state estimation and
understanding things like um gradient
descent and other kinds of methods that
we could do hidden state estimation as
largely revolved around chapter 2. Um
chapter 3 was learning and so not just
estimating hidden states but also
estimating parameters. And then chapter
4 uh and five brought us a little bit
more fully into variational inference
and the sorts of things we will more
expressly see in active inference itself
beyond the more general ideas of hidden
state and parameter estimation. And then
chapter five is predictive coding which
is sort of this um continuous state
space continuous uh time sort of way of
doing uh some of the the the earlier
forms of active inference. But we're
still not at the active part of active
inference. And in fact we won't even
still quite get there with chapter 6.
But chapter six will kind of give us
some of the foundational models such
that in chapter 7 we will go right into
the active part which is where we will
talk about um where an agent actually uh
sort of makes decisions and chooses to
do things right because so far in based
on chapter 1 and the kind of premises
that we've been working with we've
really just been looking at perception
so far and not action. Um those are sort
of two sides of uh the same coin uh in
in a sense of how active inference uh
proposes how we should uh look at those
kinds of concepts and cognitive
phenomena. So, um, for chapter 5 to wrap
up, typically what, um, oops, so sorry
about this. Um, typically what what
Frasier would do is do a bit more of
like a stepbystep,
um, walk through of the chapter. And so,
um, I won't quite be doing that given
sort of the last minute changes that
have had to happen since he's not
leading today. Um what I am going to do
and I will share these in the chat but
I've been slowly accumulating uh
different kinds of notes um on these
chapters as we go along and been putting
them into these slides. I know that I've
shared them before so maybe some folks
are getting a little tired of this but
uh um I still wanted to make them
available. And I just have uh a few
slides uh for chapter 5 specifically.
But um for those who need any kind of
refresher or still kind of you know
trying to learn some of the more general
concepts of like what is perception,
what is active learning, what is this
basian brain hypothesis and what are
sort of the more philosophical or
conceptual foundations there. Um I did
try to supply additional information
that you do and don't find in the
textbook um on how some of these things
work. Even more general things like what
is a continuous distribution? What is a
categorical distribution which we
haven't gotten into the categorical
space or discrete state space yet um in
as far as the the chapters that we've
read so far go. Um so with predictive
coding uh some things that we may not
have really fully discussed just yet uh
include what are sort of the foundations
of predictive coding where does this
come from uh we've already looked at
things like the the Ral Ballard model uh
or at least discussed it um and so a lot
of these things come out of different
sorts of studies and empirical studies
of for example how does the human uh
perceptual field work and and not just
humans but you know many experiments
have done with with with mice and and
more uh invasive neuroiming uh empirical
work and so on. And so I did want to
supply just a couple of links here. Um
two of them are more recent reviews of
pred predictive coding like how is it
used today? What are its advantages,
benefits, where is it applied? um what
are its limitations? Uh again, we're
still not talking about um sort of
active processes. We're not talking
about decision making or how an agent
makes decisions yet. And because all of
that is sort of lacking in predictive
coding, barring for uh trying to make
any sort of more hybridic model that
might include something like action. Um
yeah, we're still sort of just looking
at this more passive perceptual process,
right? So in in terms of vision, the
idea of what what is it for an agent to
take in visual information and then
represent that or make inferences about
that in the form of hidden states or
these sorts of internal states to the
model. Um but it is quite interesting.
uh so with uh another link I provided
which is to the 2022 textbook uh which
you'll find on like YouTube and
elsewhere previous um talks and
discussions around that textbook um that
we've done with the institute and many
more things. Um chapter 5 is entitled
message passing and neurobiology. Now
this phrase message passing we've not
quite seen too much in the fundamentals
of active inference textbook yet but it
will most certainly be coming up a
little bit more clearly. I think that
Sanjieve doesn't quite want to um throw
too much terminology at us too quickly
in part one because we're already
covering many many things. Um but
actually whenever we look at these kinds
of models um you know what happens is
that we're we're kind of technically um
passing messages there are these
different kinds of like encoded
information that's being passed around
throughout these models right and so the
kinds of things that we've seen so far
with basian networks we know that all
sorts of uh computations occur with
respect to uh observations and sort of
the varian on those in a in a generative
function. How do observations get
produced? Well, it's not simply a
onetoone line, but rather there's more
typically some kind of noise involved in
that. And further, there can be noise
involved in estimating hidden states.
Even different kinds of variance uh or
or noise around estimating the different
parameters. As we saw in chapter three
when we learned parameters themselves um
you know all of those are sort of
parameterized by noise terms and by by
their own respective means. Um so
these are something like messages being
passed around a graph. Um not everyone
who comes into active inference
necessarily kind of abides by that
perspective but on the whole
computationally that is how we tend to
look at things. So again, that will come
up much later. Um, but again, as far as
the roots of predictive coding go, I
really like the 2022 textbook. It's a
little bit more directly related to uh
drawing from neuroscience. And we look
at these sort of laminar columns in the
brain. And again, that phrase message
passing, you can see all these linkages
between these different nodes. Uh, you
know, these can be conceived of as
graphs. And uh this this middle uh part
of the figure here I think most closely
will be a little bit familiar to you if
you've been reading the fundamentals uh
textbook because we can see that there
are these different kinds of nodes
related to um sort of the mean or mode
uh of a hidden state inference which is
the thing that we've been going over a
lot whenever we do hidden state
estimation. And then we also have these
small um varilon symbols referring to
prediction errors. So the the more
general idea of this kind of predictive
coding uh structure is that and I tried
to include a a more all-encompassing
slide that already jumps to hierarchical
predictive coding but it's still the
same thing. It's just a hierarchical
model. The general idea is that um as
higher levels in a model
they they supply these kinds of uh
empirical priors to lower levels. So
they sort of modulate the lower levels
and the estimations there and then of
course like what is it that's correcting
those higher levels if so far all I've
said is that they correct the lower
ones. um the lower ones, especially at
the lowest level of this kind of model,
those are the ones that directly
interface with the sensorium, meaning to
say that those are the ones that
actually take in the observations from
the environment. And so that leads to
this computation of prediction errors,
right? So you can think of the higher
levels as kind of deeper and deeper as
we go. And this gets related to um deep
um uh deep granular cells in the brain
whereas the the lower ones are more
related to like superficial cells. Um
what what happens is that we we have
these ascending prediction errors that
is we take in information we thought
something based upon our higher level
priors. um but that needs to be
corrected by the fact that we might have
received observations that don't
actually correspond to um what we our
model predicted. Right? So
this relates to a lot of theories of
things like efficient coding in the
brain. Uh which is where it's a general
theory that perhaps it's the case that
organisms generally evolved to be able
to handle uh environmental information
that they receive in a rather efficient
way. Um it kind of aligns with general
ideas of evolution and metabolism and
the rest. Um and so what we end up with
is this interesting hierarchical
structure where again um this is uh
equation 5.3 in chapter 5. It's sort of
like each one of these sort of uh lines
in our generative model with that like
math cow style m uh that's the
generative model or the agent um is the
agent is represented by each of these
levels where they're all passing
information between each other. in the
brackets we see that these are
references to what particular level
we're at. So this sensory mapping layer
is sort of the lowest level uh that I
mentioned earlier. It's what actually
takes in your why, your observations.
And then at the next level up, we can
see that the next level up is actually
going to try to predict what that uh
mode should be that that mean estimate
should be at level one given what is
going on in level two. Right? So we have
all these different estimations that are
going on at each level and each one of
them is carrying out a very similar sort
of process. Um where there's hidden
state estimation uh where there is as in
chapter 3 parameter estimation uh we
have uh as far as using the sort of
variational free energy form of these
things we're calculating uh free energy
at each of these respective levels as
they sort of predict one another. Um
again hearkening back to the laminar
column uh sort of description where we
do indeed have these different cortical
layers in the brain and thus there's
this kind of hierarchy between them
where they interact. So that's where a
lot of that comes from because the
fundamentals of active inference
textbook of course is more labeled
towards engineers. Um it's in the
subtitle of the textbook. So um we don't
quite get that picture of where some of
these things come from. Although Sanjie
does a a nice job at the very end of the
chapter of kind of briefly rehearsing uh
the relationship between these things
and sort of the history of where they
come from. So with all of that said um
and then also yeah these these more
recent reviews I think are quite good.
Um especially this this I mean they're
both good. Millage is great. Um but it's
just um that's from about four years
ago. Um Smith's paper here um is a
little bit more recent. He actually did
a talk with the institute. So it's
worthwhile if you were to just like
search this up on YouTube. Um a talk
that he and his uh research assistants
who co-authored um gave uh on on this
paper. of course it's paywalt um so it's
worthwhile to sort of check out uh the
talk that was given on it gives you much
more information about what happened in
the paper um I didn't say this but the
the phrase canonical microcircuit uh
that's another interesting thing to be
thinking about or or discussing with
reference to to predictive coding in
fact that's quite literally what this is
whenever we look at these different
cortical layers right there this is
essentially what's what's phrased as a
canonical microcircuit. We're looking at
some kind of particular some kind of uh
region in the brain and not just what
goes on in that region, but what
potentially goes on at all of these
different levels in that region. And
then the reason why this um chapter five
in that textbook is called message
passing and neurobiology is we're we're
looking at all these different regions
in the brain and how that kind of
message passing that kind of variational
inference and and free energy
minimization works. Um so something I'd
like to get into and this is quite a
slide. Um I tried to be as comprehensive
as possible but it starts to look like
its own kind of very large textbook. Um
this is a slide on squared precision
weighted prediction errors. Um what I
attempted to do was trace out throughout
the chapter what Sanjieve actually does
like how he sort of leads us through all
of this because of course we know he as
any chapter we nicely break it up into
like section 5.1 5.2 2 and so on. But I
wanted to try and compress that um
across the sections so that we could get
a little bit more of a singular picture.
And it's something that's worth sort of
working through step by step because a
lot of these sorts of um algorithms and
and the general flow of these processes
is going to um again be rehearsed in
later later chapters. Um so we started
with the E form of of uh variational
free energy. We were looking at these uh
entropy and energy terms. We had an
interesting discussion about those last
week. Couple things about the
nomenclature and excuse me and the way
that those equations are presented. Um
the the primary thing is just
recognizing that we're still working
with free energy and we're still sort of
working with these two different terms
and trying to minimize free energy
itself as a proxy for surprisal. Um that
is we want to be able to have a model
that is quite good at predicting the
observations it receives. um while also
sort of minimizing something like
complexity or minimizing uh something
like um in terms of metabolic aspects
that is you can have a really good model
but if it's incredibly complex such that
it adds something like a a heavy
computational overload uh you know for a
computer program you'd view it as oh
this takes a very long time to run it's
not exactly feasible in in real life in
reality um and you can think of a of a
person of trying to uh someone who's
perceiving something and trying to make
sense of it by seeing it, right? Like
they they take in sensory information,
they're trying to infer, okay, what does
this information mean? If it takes them
an incredibly long time, in a more
general sense, we would see that as well
that that might be uh not terribly
useful in real life circumstances
whenever life throws everything at you
in real time uh you know, rather
quickly. And so that's where some of
these variational uh inference methods
sort of come from. And so we're still
doing that, but here we're going to do a
very particular form of it. Um and it's
the particular form we're doing relates
to the idea of a mean field
approximation which we already talked
about uh in the previous chapter. But
the the general notion of mean field is
that what you can do is you can you can
reduce a lot of complexity in a model by
first assuming that everything in the
model can kind of be factorized. Uh
right we know that it's very difficult
to and potentially entirely intractable
to compute model evidence. Um but
because we're looking at these big joint
state spaces, right? We're looking at
these big joint distributions uh between
a variety of things like parameters and
so on. Like if we actually took each of
these and looked at them not as their
own distinct distributions or parameters
or otherwise, but instead kind of
multiplied them all together, we'd end
up with this very massive space uh
multi-dimensional space that
computationally it it would be quite
difficult, potentially impossible to uh
actually navigate that to run
computations over that. But uh if what
we could do instead is say each one of
them gets updated sort of separately
like we can update our hidden states
given the observation we receive and all
of our parameters
and we could estimate one of our
parameters given all of the other
parameters and the hidden state estimate
and the observation we received. So you
can see like we estimate things sort of
in this peace meal fashion where we can
estimate one thing given all of the
other things. We're able to do that
through factorizing uh by by being able
to treat them separately and uh we'll
see in chapter 6 that we're very
frequently assuming a lot of
independence between these things and
that's what allows us to do the
factorization. Does that mean we can
potentially miss relationships between
these variables? What happens whenever
they they kind of um you know they both
have noise and they both have variance
but sometimes that variance can kind of
correlate with each other right oh as x
goes down the the estimate for this
other parameter tends to go down too
shouldn't we sort of exploit that
relationship or uh you know um the the
store is open during the daytime and
it's closed during the night time right
the these are things that relate to one
another um so we and potentially miss uh
different kinds of rich or potentially
significant information that would help
us to achieve um sort of a more
thoroughly considered uh interconnected
or very deep uh you know estimate or or
hypothesis about what's going on in the
world. But that's sort of the thing
right is that if we we had that degree
of complexity in every single
computation we made we run into the uh
interactability problem mathematically
and then just in real life circumstances
you know for me to go uh you know a few
blocks up the street to go get my
groceries I don't necessarily need to be
thinking and factoring into my decision-
making what happens on the opposite side
of the world. uh right like to bring
that into I don't need to globally think
about the entire state space of
everything there is to think about uh
right so there's there is a a realism to
this beyond just viewing it as some sort
of mathematical trick or otherwise so um
brief note on the nomenclature here once
we do have or apply this sort of mean
field approximation Sanjie does start
using this symbol
It's called a var theta and it's just a
way of nicely collecting all these
things together and just um it's for the
sake of notation right so var theta here
is basically going to include your
hidden state that you're estimating as
well as the parameters you're estimating
they're basically everything in your
model uh ignoring the sensory
information you receive because the
sensory information you receive the why
the observation itself sort of
independent of you and it's sort of
taken is a given whenever you receive
it. That's the only thing you you don't
estimate unless you want to invert your
model and predict it. So I've been going
into um perhaps a little bit too much
detail about you know looking back at
chapter 4. So I want to go into chapter
5 because here we're looking at
prediction errors which we've already
sort of discussed. But the more general
thing is that once we know that we're
going to be minimizing variational free
energy um the simplification that
Sanjief makes and not just that he makes
but this is a particular algorithm
that's applied elsewhere is how do we
simplify this even further? Um, what's
one way of demonstrating how predictive
coding works in a way that you might
still apply in empirical reality and
research or experimentation or otherwise
even though it's not the only way to
necessarily do it. Uh, we've been
talking about estimating entire
distributions using basian inference and
so on. Um, but here instead of
estimating the entire posterior
distribution, we're really just going to
focus in this more simplified version.
Um, we're going to be estimating just
the the the mean or the mode of our
hidden state distribution. Right? So,
that ends up looking like a nice little
point instead of a instead of a full
Gaussian distribution. We're just going
to be looking at what if we kind of
quote unquote clamp uh that mean
estimate and we're just trying to to
figure out that like what's our best our
best sort of estimate of like the the
singular value instead of a whole
distribution what it what uh you know
represents our hidden state in the
model. So whenever we kind of follow the
math along we're still doing a lot of
things that are similar to before. We're
still supplying priors on our likelihood
and our our uh our prior our uh mean
estimate uh prior itself. So these are
sort of like we're supplying these
normal distributions so we can estimate
each of those things. Again this comes
back to chapters up to now. Um we've
been doing that the whole time but now
we're including these prediction errors
uh again the epsilon term. And so
whenever we do that, what we're actually
doing is that we're weighting our
estimates based on these prediction
errors. Sort of like saying, well,
whenever I estimate something, how much
can I actually trust my new estimation,
right? Um, if a person is in the dark,
uh, and they think they see something,
uh, it's a little bit harder to trust
that sensory observation and what your
brain made of that whenever it's dark
because, uh, we we, you know, there's
kind of more noise in the process. The
darkness makes it more difficult to make
out what that is. Uh, and so maybe we
cannot necessarily trust our inference.
like our our best guess that singular
that singular clamped value would say
well it's just one thing right it's not
a whole distribution with uncertainty
it's just there's one specific estimate
you know there's one specific estimate
of what food size is based on the
observation of light intensity to refer
to the the the frequent example that
that Sanjieve employs in the examples
right but if it's dark then maybe
there's this amount of food or maybe
there's a larger amount of food, it's a
little bit more difficult because
there's a lot of noise in the way that
I'm taking this in. And I know that
because it's it's dark, right? If
there's much more light, I might be more
confident. So, um, that's what's
important about thinking about
prediction errors and this sort of
precision weighted prediction error. um
whenever a prediction error occurs.
These are the much simpler sort of um
perhaps I should have started with this
but the more simpler way of viewing it
is um you have sensory prediction errors
then you have state prediction errors.
Whenever we run through this entire
algorithm which is where essentially uh
you know for some duration of time you
know between now and 2 minutes from now
um one way of looking at it is that for
each sort of time step in that process I
take in an observation or y and then
after that I'm going to calculate the
variational free energy to do my hidden
state estimation that's in step for here
uh shown in equation 5.16
again we're including the prediction
errors now that kind of scale my
estimate differently depending on how
much I can actually trust the
observation
um then after that we will finally
update our hidden state now that we've
calculated the free energy that kind of
we we we use that to figure out what our
in state is so the hidden state at the
next time step is what it was before
minus this partial derivative of
variational free energy with respect to
the the estimate we had before. As we've
seen before as well with a lot of this,
this looks incredibly similar to the
update equations we've seen in previous
chapters. We're still scaling that by
some kind of learning rate um kappa. And
then whenever we do that, we can
calculate our prediction errors. Well,
now that we've updated our mean uh just
now, um what was the difference between
our updated mean versus the mean that we
had before? If it's massive, then we
could say that there's a very strong
state prediction error. That is, our
model could not very well account for
this observation. we ended up with this
very large prediction error where we
actually had to update our model quite a
bit to adjust for the new observation.
Right? So that would be a very high
state prediction error. Um and then
conversely whenever we use our new
estimated mean to figure out sort of
invert the model like well what was the
observation I should have seen versus
the one I actually got. That is our
sensory prediction error. Right? So each
of those terms then figure back into
this. Whenever we calculate them, we
recalculate the variational free energy
yet again to account for those
prediction errors. Right? So this is a
kind of corrective adaptive process that
uses the fact that we may or may not be
able to trust our model um uh our
previous model because it might have had
a very high state prediction error. And
it also might be that we can't really
trust what it led us to think would
happen in terms of observation we
received as well. So that's the general
sense of prediction errors. Then the
precision weighted aspect that's the
specifically the trust aspect and that's
what Sanjief makes reference to as well.
It's a kind of confidence right. Um it's
saying like oh a very high precision
means I can trust this prediction error.
I can trust that I need to update my
model using the prediction error that I
found. I use that correctively as
opposed to a low precision, which is
that sort of being in the dark example.
It's like, well, I'm in the dark and I
thought I saw a person, right? And
that's maybe something that was alarming
because I didn't expect there to be a
person. So, I end up with this high
state prediction error. I end up with a
very high sensory prediction error, but
I'm in the dark. So just because I had
these massive errors, it doesn't mean I
should trust that that was really a
person, right? Um it depends on the
circumstance at hand, you know, if if
you're in the dark in your own room and
you're just waking up from a bad dream
or something, you know, that we might
say, "Oh, there's very low precision
about seeing a person, you know, that
might been a brief hallucination
whenever I was waking up from a dream or
something." as opposed to, you know, uh,
more of a a horror movie where someone's
in the dark and actually that that was a
person in the dark that they didn't
expect. Um, you know, so those those
kinds of
pseudo common sensical ways of thinking
about it I hope are sort of useful for
thinking about the role of precision
weighted prediction errors. Um, and then
I already spent some time talking about
the hierarchical aspects, but just again
it's the the general sense is we're now
using these prediction errors, but we're
using them whenever we compute these all
of these different things, the hidden
state, the the the parameter learning,
and all the rest that we've already
talked about at each one of these
respective levels, right? Um
so yeah we're just given um in this
figure 5.16 again it's a a basian
network which is basically what's called
a graphical model. We haven't seen the
phrase message passing much yet but
still again it's it's you if you think
about these these circles are called
nodes and the lines are called edges. Um
what's happening is that we're getting
this kind of estimation this pri prior
expectation or or or prediction at a
higher level and it's sort of a message
that's being passed to inference
occurring at another level. And then
that relates back to how cortical or
laminar layers in the brain actually
communicate with with one another. Um,
and then another interesting thing is
that oftentimes we'll see that these
layers actually look quite similar to
one another in different sorts of ways.
Um, there are different theories of why
this kind of communication might happen
this way. We can think of a prior as
something that sort of regularizes or or
or penalizes strong changes to our
model. Um it it's something that sort of
grounds us to have prior expectations is
what allows us to you know not have our
attention and massive prediction errors
by being thrown off by every single
observation we receive rather um the
priors kind of keep us grounded by
saying like okay well I don't want to
update my model too much not just for
metabolic reasons but because I can lose
lose stability in my model and it won't
be very robust to noise, right? If you
have like a robot that has a sort of
sensor on it and that sensor sort of
goes off for a second, you know, there's
a slight shortcircuiting and in the the
electronics and so suddenly a a sensor
reading jumps from around a five on
average to a 1,000 for a single time
step. Really, it's just because of this
brief malfunction that happened, right?
So, we don't want that that robot to
suddenly update all of its beliefs or
hidden state estimations rapidly because
it received that singular value as if it
was a real value. The environment maybe
didn't actually change at all. It's just
it was a bad sensor reading for a blip
in time, right? And so, it's the priors
that help the model say, "Oh, don't
update too quickly." Um, this might just
be sort of a, you know, a fluke. this
might be a sort of brief uh issue and
the environment didn't really change and
so it doesn't call for some sort of
drastic massive update in in my model.
Um so that's sort of one way that we can
conceive of priors and then we can think
of each of these higher levels as even
further slowing down the process of
inference. in a lot of these sort of
deeper levels in the in the brain um and
just in the the more abstract predicting
uh predictive coding architecture in
general. Um they do tend to kind of work
at a slower time scale. uh Sanjie
doesn't quite say that in chapter 5
because he just wants to introduce us to
how this works and so he doesn't quite
jump ahead to saying like oh not only
that but we would actually a more
realistic version of predictive coding
would have a slightly different
algorithm where it would say oh at every
time step it's only the lowest level the
one that directly interfaces with um
with uh reality with the sensorium the
sensory mapping layer right the lowest
level. Um, that's the one that would
probably actually function at each time
step. Whereas another layer would uh the
next level up would function just a
little bit more slowly. It might not
update at every single time step. But
mathematically we might say that it
updates at every other time step, right?
like a accumulation of of information
that kind of gets uh pushed upward
through ascending prediction errors and
then a kind of slower updating uh and
communication between the layers. And a
lot of that relates back to again um
with with neuroscience and neuroiming um
you know a slower moving layer, higher
layer. It doesn't necessarily mean
slower in the sense of you know oh it
only updates every hour. It might still
be updating very quickly. it just might
not be at the same exact rate as as sort
of the the lowest layers. And that
starts getting into things like whenever
you look at frequency bands or neuronal
images uh excuse me neuronal uh rhythms
in in neuroiming. Um there many
phenomena that are really well known
like we frequently see this kind of
crossoupling between uh theta and gamma
uh rhythms. Whenever someone is learning
something like the brain is actually
learning information and not just sort
of uh passively uh briefly perceiving
without learning anything. It's like we
see these distinct uh neuronal rhythms
that occur with that align with
different forms of cognitive phenomena
and behavior. And so um the theta and
gamma I mean theta is just a slower
rhythm than what gamma is. Gamma is
faster, right? So we have these
processes happening in the brain where
different processes happen at different
time scales and it's actually sort of
the combination of them the combination
of these different like multi-time
scales that leads to the kind of
interesting phenomena we see. So um we
would have something for a more
empirically like relevant form of
predictive coding. we would have this
operation in different time scales and
that is relevant because it will come up
in later chapters as well whenever we
look at when we actually put in decision
making and action right um we might have
a kind of a slower higher level planning
that occurs like oh I need to get to the
airport um and then a faster time scale
would say in order to get to the airport
I need to take the bus to stop number
one and then at stop number one that
will take to the um uh airport from stop
one, right? So, it's a little bit more
granular and an even faster time scale.
Uh in order to get to stop number one, I
actually have to walk out of my house to
get to the the first bus stop, right?
And and so it's it's just even more um
sequences of of sort of steps that all
operate at their own respective time
scales and then they sort of communicate
and hopefully kind of converge with one
another such that we accomplish the goal
or or more generally we update our model
more appropriately and allows us to to
adapt to um sort of the environment and
whatever it is that we're hoping to do.
Um, so I spent a very good deal of time
um, talking about all of that. So I'd
like to just take a moment and see if
there were any kinds of questions that
might have come up during this. And if
not, uh, no worries at all. We can
always kind of hop over to the questions
that have been asked on the KOD as well.
Um, so I would like to just take a
moment if anyone does have a sort of
question they might like to ask, whether
it be unmuting yourself and saying
something or it just be like dropping
something in the chat here. Um, totally
respect everyone's privacy and however
much you'd like to sort of engage in
that. Um, but yeah, just just let me
know and I'm going to quickly look at
some of the questions that have been
asked.
Okay. Um so so for the chapter 5
questions that were asked um one thing
came up. So the maximum entropy
principle uh more entropy equals more
choices or degrees of freedom which
equals more options to learn. Um we did
not go very strongly into the maximum
entry uh entropy principle so far in the
textbook chapters 1 through 5 but there
have been multiple references to it. Um
this is a very interesting thing that
relates to um this this sort of
penultimate question of okay so if I'm
going to sit down and I'm going to
construct a model um what should those
initial priors be right active inference
doesn't really give a thorough origin
story of what the priors sort of where
they come from right like it okay great
we we're updating our prior through
parameter learning and hidden state
estimation that's great but what where
did it start at what point? You know,
we're always starting at time step one.
Uh but what defines all the things at
time step uh you know t minus one or or
one minus one you know some some
previous how did we get here basically
to start this this active inference
loop. Um it's it's it's it's
difficult to say. I mean
philosophically, theoretically, people
start looking at things like like human
and other organismal uh evolution. They
look at things like what I mentioned
earlier, the efficient coding hypothesis
that there might be some sort of uh
processes involved and and aspects of
our neurobiology that that make us uh
particularly equipped sort of at the
onset uh you know sort of effectively
out of the womb uh you know with some
kind of priors that might be helpful or
not. Um but but how do we handle that
kind of uh ambiguity mathematically
including for engineers who are not
interested or concerned with with you
know specifically biological organisms
or maybe uh more interested in
artificial intelligence you know so so
we're looking more at like well what is
one way we could approach that sort of
mathematically what what seems to be
sort of best um the maximum entropy
principle which for those who are
familiar with things like distributions
um statistics and the like. Um the
maximum entropy principle would sort of
say that we should start with something
like a uniform distribution. Um the the
uniform distribution
is not
something that you want to end up with
after updating your model. Um a a
uniform distribution. And you notice
before we've been looking at these these
nice normal distributions, these
Gaussians like this one here, right? It
had it's mean it this is very
specifically a Gaussian. Uh it it's
centered at zero. So it's nice. we have
this kind of you know um there's some
degree of uncertainty over what the
estimate should be but most likely more
or less if we just did a quick u you
know just kind of extract out the mode
and say what's the best guess should be
about a zero right uniform distribution
uh doesn't have that sort of bias about
it a uniform distribution looks like
this kind of like this rectangle or or
squarel-like structure it's saying that
you know for some range
uh the the the the probability is equal
uh for all potential values, right? That
means we don't have a best guess. We
don't have a sort of a a nice mean that
we can actually trust. um the point over
here at point A is just as valid as
point B is just as valid as point C or D
or you know if we we could put in
another E over here and an F over here
they would all be equivalent right um
that's in in actual practice that that's
kind of awful um it means you're not
able to make any kind of good uh
specific guess about about anything uh
there's virtually no uh sort of
precision uh very high variance uh right
it could be any of these values um and
if we're looking at a purely continuous
space I mean each one of these like
little points we could make would be
infantesimally small right so we we
would have a a sort of equal probability
for an infinite range of values um
that's what I mean whenever I say uh in
in sort of this crude way like this is
this is uniform distribution is sort of
awful for making different kinds of
inferences or guesses or otherwise. So
why would we care about this? Um the
maximum entropy principle says when you
make a prior, you know, just imagine a
new agent in the world for the very
first time engaging with its environment
that it knows virtually nothing about
other than the agent has some kind of
generative model, you know, that it
virtually hasn't learned anything yet.
Um we'd actually want our prior to look
like this. Why is that? Um that's it's
what the maximum entropy principle would
say. This comes out of uh the the
mathematician and physicist uh Jane's
work uh largely in the the 50s and
relates to things like information
theory. But another way you can look at
it is you know if a person comes into
the the world or maybe a little more
realistically you're going to play a
game uh for the first time and you've
never played the game before. You don't
know how it works. You don't know what
you should expect. things like that. If
you started in advance
with a very sharp distribution that is
kind of centered around a very
particular value, that means in advance
you're already going to be biased to
perceiving the world in a particular
way, right? Um we're already going to be
very biased towards estimating a hidden
state around here. And and if we looked
at sort of the the likelihood
distribution and it was also a very
sharp normal distribution uh or or or
even sharper than a standard normal
distribution. The idea is that we'd
already be biased to view things in a
particular way. And if we don't know
enough about the world, which again in
this situation I'm describing, it's it's
a world where the agent knows nothing
about it yet. It hasn't started
receiving observations yet. is just
about to start its own nice little uh
loop here of of inference and state
estimation and and minimizing free
energy and surprisal and all the rest.
Um to start with the uniform
distribution would be to say oh I'm not
biased in any particular direction not
yet. So what what we would say is that
you could have a sort of uniform
distribution that looks like this
incredibly high virtually infinite uh
variance. Um and then from there you
start to receive observations and then
we get this we could start having this
sort of sharpening of the distribution
where instead of it being this kind of
odd rectangular shape it would start
becoming more biased around say ideally
a normal distribution. We might hope you
know you could end up with this sort of
biodal distribution. Whenever it turns
out that actually maybe there are two
different major things going on in the
environment. It's usually one or the
other that leads to this kind of
singular distribution that that actually
has two um you know kind of kind of uh
potentially equivalently found modes. Um
but uh again so far with with the the
setup we've been looking at we are
parameterizing everything with normal
distribution. So it's just sort of the
idea is that our model gets better over
time in simplest terms. Like over time
we want our model to start to better
match the environment and we're
frequently assuming the environment does
something like following um a normal
distribution. And that doesn't just bear
out from trying to heavily um minimize
complexity and make a bunch of
assumptions about the environment in
advance. It's in part um because um
we're we're just attempting to um sort
of recognize some of the the the the
interesting things we find in
mathematics, the central limit theorem
for those who are uh familiar with that.
But it's just sort of if you continue to
uh pull observation sample distrib uh
excuse me sample observations or data
points from a distribution in this case
if you continue to receive observations
from the environment and you actually
just look at what those look like on a
graph where you're not imposing
anything. You're not imposing a
particular distribution. You're not
shoving a normal distribution onto it as
the way to view it. It's just you're
just looking at the data plotted. Um,
typically it does start to look like a
normal distribution which is very
interesting. Like even if the generative
process itself doesn't follow a normal
distribution continuously sampling from
it, the data points you collect will
start to look normal. Um it's a very
interesting thing that better uh sort of
um provides more evidence for why we use
all these normal distributions beyond
just viewing it as some kind of ad hoc
thing that just makes it simpler so that
life is easier you know um even though
life does need to be easier in a sort of
metabolic sense. Um
so I think
quickly look at
further. Okay. Um might just look at one
more question.
Um
something that I think was already
addressed last week but um this uh page
118 very last sentence prediction error
becomes equal to the current value of mu
of x. Shouldn't this be mu of x uh m of
x instead of mu of x? Um that's
related to um the nice fancy word we've
been using arada in the textbook where
we've been trying to see in this
textbook given it was just published are
there any sort of typos that were made
uh in the textbook. But some things were
were have been decidedly found to be
typos and then others have not actually
been typos. There's just a slight
ambiguity. Um so with this I I point to
equation 5.6b here real quick on state
prediction error because this is what
they're talking about. Mu ofx
uh minus m ofx equals our state
prediction error which is what the the
question is asking about. Um, so the the
thing here is that m of x is really just
being used to say this is not what our
current updated mean now that we've just
updated it looks like. Right? So he
we're really just using the m ofx to
quickly show like well this is what uh
mu of x was before we just updated it.
Uh what we could also do alternatively
is we could say mu of x at time step one
minus mu of x at time step t minus one,
right? Or or or or or 1 minus one. Um
you you can see how it gets kind of odd
to talk about it, right? So it's just to
say what is the updated mean at the new
time step minus what it was before the
new time step. That's our state
prediction error. What did I think
before? What do I think now? What's the
difference between what I think now? The
updated mean and what I thought before.
That's a state prediction error, right?
So, so the m of x is really just one way
of trying to kind of compress all of
that phrasing to just say what you know
what is it now minus what it was before.
And then it's that it we follow the same
logic for sensory prediction error. It's
like well our previous estimate mu of x
you know this this very well could be um
well no we've updated the mean right so
then we can plug that updated mean to
try and figure out inverter model and
say well what should the y have been at
the next time step um but then we get to
compare that to the actual one we
receive right it's like well I expected
to see um I expected to see a tree but
it turns out I saw a person um you know
it's not the best thing cuz I can't um
one to one in the minutes we have like
say how how that works in terms of
numbers um but if you could imagine that
we we could kind of do that or we could
look at you know what what was the light
intensity
supposed to be now that I fig now that I
updated my belief about the food size
can I use that to say well what what
should the light intensity that
corresponds to that be and then what's
the actual light intensity that I
observed um find the difference between
knows that's your sensory prediction
error and then again that then gets
precision weighted um uh meaning that
can I trust that prediction error
because how much should I let that
prediction error guide the update in my
model and that's why we do this thing
where we recalculate the prediction
errors again after receive the
observation and update our hidden state
and then we recalculate variational free
energy and then the interesting thing
about hierarchical models is that each
one of these layers is doing that. Um
you know each of these layers in the
model is minimizing free energy and all
the rest. But then uh Sanjief says um we
can actually sort of additively look at
the the free energy at each of these
levels to see uh what is sort of a
global variational free energy. Right?
We want to see the global vari. If if we
want to minimize variational free energy
at level one and we want to minimize it
at level two and we want to minimize it
at level three, then we would want to
know, you know, as an experimentter who
creates these models, we would want to
know what the variational free energy is
at each level because maybe the first
level is doing great. It's minimizing
variational free energy to virtually a
zero. uh meaning it would also be very
strongly minimizing surprise and getting
to be a very very good model or at least
a very good layer in our overall global
model. Um but then maybe another layer
isn't doing so great at variational free
energy minimization. So that's how you
could kind of distinguish what's going
on at each layer. But then if you add up
all of those, you could also see if you
have a a kind of a good model in general
by seeing does this global variational
free energy reduce. And that's sort of
one of the aspects of just predictive
coding and active inference more
generally when we do variational free
energy. It's like well every single one
of these things that we're updating um
our ability to predict observations or
hidden state estimations or parameters
that we're learning all of these come
back to variational free energy and
being able to sort of factoriize each of
these little components in the model. We
can use variational free energy to
update our hidden state estimate. We can
use it to update our parameters. We use
it to qualify how good a model is in
general um and com use variational free
energy um to to sort of score models
against one another and then determine
if one model is much better or not
versus another. Um and then finally we
can score the overall uh goodness let's
say of a of a hierarchical model by
looking at kind of this global free
energy that's getting minimized
everywhere. Um so yeah um we won't
throughout the rest of the textbook come
back too strongly to predictive coding
which is again why I wanted to just
supply a couple you know more recent
papers that kind of discuss uh the
current status of predictive coding and
how it's being used and where and why
and what sorts of um what sorts of new
formulations have come from that. Um
there will be very interesting things I
think in the near future where some
people are actually doing things like um
sort of uh uh quantum predictive coding
uh where they're actually using not just
um probability distributions in the way
we have but actually being able to look
at things like quantum states and the
rest. So for those who are interested in
quantum mechanics and the like um those
sorts of things will be quite
interesting but of course they don't
have to overtake the work that's already
been done. Not everyone is interested in
sort of looking at things in a quantum
fashion. Like maybe they're more focused
on getting a little bit higher precision
and assuming the world is a little bit
more deterministic just for the sake of
having a little bit more concrete,
clearer empirical work where there are
different kinds of takeaways or
findings. Um so yeah, I I I personally
find predictive coding very interesting.
I've uh been interested in how it's
applied been applied in different um
areas for sort of fitting it to
empirical data and behavior, how it's
been mapped to the the different laminar
columns in the brain um and how well it
kind of uh accounts for the different
sorts of things that we see in
neuroiming data. And then finally uh
what we'll see in the textbook is we'll
be extrapolating the lot a lot of the
principles here not just for thinking
about how we can model a neuronal
population in in a particular cortical
column in the brain but even more
generally at a at a larger scale or a a
larger uh less nested uh marov blanket
to put it that way. Um how does an
entire organism function uh whenever we
apply these different kinds of
principles? How and especially in
chapter 7 when we start introducing
action and decision making sort of into
the equation. That is how can we use
this the these these principles that go
into understanding
um you know cortical microcircuits. How
can we apply those to an entire uh
organism? How it makes decisions and you
know how the different parts of its body
uh and different parts of the brain kind
of interact with one another. So I do
again recommend the 2022 textbook
because these things get applied um you
know to different kinds of sensory
observations. They get applied to
proprioceptive data and reflex arcs like
how does an arm move and and how does
how does a being like move their arm to
where it needs to go. You know these
sorts of things that we don't just think
about areas of the brain but we think
about motor connectivity and how the
rest of the body relates. And we'll see
in chapter six there are references to
things like adaptive control and control
theory and how does an organism kind of
um you know not just within the deepest
areas of of superficial and and
pyramidal parameal cells in the brain
but like more broadly how does it its
entire body move and function in a a
real world. So I think I've already gone
over a little bit on time and um I don't
think we have too many questions. So
again, next week we will come back to um
we will come back to
a review of part one. Um and then I
think Frasier I I will do my best to be
there, but then I'm I'm fairly certain
Frasier will be there. Daniel would
normally do the session on Tuesday, but
he is um not available uh for once. Um
he's we've all been pretty diligent
about keeping up with this. So um yeah
uh part one. So with respect to that
there's no like required reading so to
speak though um I've already you know
been getting into chapter 6 and I see
that some other folks have been as well.
So it is worthwhile to have a brief uh
look at um you know not quite chapter 6
but between chapter 5 and chapter 6
there's just this three-page discussion
of uh part two what it will entail. Um
and so I I do strongly suggest looking
at that because it'll kind of orient us
for after this part one review how we'll
be looking at part two and it'll be much
more I think interesting in terms of
applications. So, um I just want to
thank everyone for attending today and
uh I will now stop the recording. Thank
you very much and we'll we'll see you
soon.